Drake says he's disheartened emotional
and truly scared over Tuesday's death of
Alton sterling
he's a 37 year old father of five who
was shot by police multiple times
outside the convenience store in Baton
Rouge Louisiana where he regularly sold
homemade CDs yeah in an emotional open
letter the Toronto rapper writes on
Instagram it's impossible to ignore that
the relationship between black and brown
communities and law enforcement remains
as strained as it was decades ago no one
begins their life as a hash tag yet the
trend of being reduced to one continues
then after expressing concern over the
safety of his family and friends Drake
admits I do not know the answer but I
believe things can change for the better
open and honest dialogue is the first
step yeah wise words but unfortunately
the violence continues Wednesday night
in a suburb of st. Paul Minnesota 32
year-old falando Castile was shot by
police during a routine traffic stop and
the horrific aftermath was caught by his
girlfriend on Facebook live while her
four year old daughter sat in the back
of the car yeah and we have decided not
to show you guys the graphic video but
it is certainly not stopping celebs from
reacting on Twitter John Legend tweets
let's go NRA I know y'all are for the
Second Amendment are you also for equal
protection while josh groban says there
are so many broken backwards issues at
play here it's numbing to digest